comme chaque vendredi nous vous
proposons une chronique spéciale pour
les juniors aujourd'hui notre
journaliste sportif michael et demi
d'euros est avec nous en plateau pour
nous parler des championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste bonjour michael
bonjour camille j'espère que vous allez
bien depuis la semaine dernière
alors vous disiez a précédemment je vais
vous parler des championnats d'europe de
cyclisme sur piste la compétition a
débuté à ce mercredi se poursuivra
jusqu'à ce dimanche au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous allez me dire mais quel est le
rapport avec la chronique junior mickaël
je vous réponde camille cette deuxième
compétition internationale organisée à
part le vélodrome après les championnats
du monde 2015 à dire beaucoup de jeunes
et en particulier des enfants comme on
peut le voir sur cette séquence
intéresser tout fait impressionné j'ai
dû surtout juste à la télé d'habitude
mais je suis impressionné la vitesse le
fait qui passe juste à côté
je serais peut-être pas venu si les
enfants parce que c'est lui qui m'a un
petit peu a incité ce soir à venir c'est
une sortie en famille oui parce que
gérer pour les jeunes ils veulent voir
un petit peu les sports on a la chance
d'avoir un vélo droit à 50 ans
selon le jeune homme venu ici ce soir je
suis tout ça change parce que d'habitude
on parle des matchs de foot du rugby et
n'était jamais allé alors ça va tu as
et si vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincu
je vais vous donner trois raisons pour
venir au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin les mines ce week-end avec
vos enfants
c'est un championnat d'europe c'est un
événement spectaculaire imaginer un vélo
lancé à plus de 60 kilomètres heure sur
une piste de 250 mètres de long avec sur
les côtés une pente à 45 degrés notre
consultant ian dujarrier en est persuadé
les enfants adorent ce sport est en
effet c'est un spectacle qui est facile
à partager la rigueur avec ses avec ses
enfants
à partir d'un certain âge quand ils ont
la patience de pouvoir attendre quelques
heures parce que c'est un spectacle qui
se renouvelle que
tout le temps mais qui dure qui dure
quand même un bon ami moment et c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qui se
partager les enfants généralement aime
beaucoup parce qu'il ya une usine
communion avec avec le public avec les
avec les sorties système quoi va la vie
kech et après j'aime bien les virages
qu'ancien climie c'est très pentu et à
la télé vous le dirais pas que c'est que
c'est comme ça alors on peut dire que
vous avez à marquer un point michael on
passe maintenant à notre deuxième raison
est effectivement les championnats
d'europe offre également la possibilité
aux enfants de voir d'autres nations aux
étrangères c'est un petit peu un cours
de géographie à accélérer camille il y à
28 pays sur cette compétition on
retrouve les meilleures nations de
l'europe la grande bretagne qui a
triomphé lors des derniers jo de rio
l'italie la russie ou encore l'allemagne
mais on peut également voir des pays un
petit peu moins connus comme la
biélorussie ou la slovaquie
en tout cas les sportifs sont tous ravis
d'être ici nous les avons rencontrés
incroyable c'est aussi très bien d'être
encore en france mais j'aime bien la
langue
j'aime bien aussi
la france en général comme ça c'est trop
bien d'être ici je pense que c'est
vraiment très bien d'être ici
j'aime bien la piste c'est vraiment très
sympa c'est un gros événement au 3ème qt
aujourd'hui pour regarder vers le futur
alors il n'y a pas que les nations
étrangères michael ya aussi et surtout
l'équipe de france oui on arrive au 3e
point sûrement le plus important camille
l'équipe de france est en opération
reconquête après le fiasco des jo de rio
avec une seule médaille de bronze
la fédération a lancé à des petits
jeunes sur la piste l'équipe de france
d'endurance qui a remporté l'or hier
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
et emmenés par un trappistes benjamin
thomas qui à tout juste 21 ans et
florian m 19 ans la génération qui sera
aux jo de 2024 en france les enfants
adorent les champions camille et ses
garçons le sont sûrement pour les
prochains jo de 2024 qui seront
peut-être organisée à paris en écoute
vincent jacquet le dtn de l'équipe de
france il nous parle justement de cette
jeune génération
c'est un bel avantage puisque ça veut
dire qu'on a de la réserve
ça veut dire que derrière on a toute une
génération qu'on souhaite accompagner à
grandir et et derrière un petit à petit
la guérir a fait assez grande
compétition internationale
alors si on veut voir cette belle équipe
de france le tarif est de 11 euros pour
les enfants et de 18 euros pour les
adultes
si vous habitez à saint quentin en
yvelines vous pouvez bénéficier d'un
tarif réduit il vous suffit juste de
venir à l'accueil du vélodrome avec un
justificatif de domicile
j'y vais ce week-end camille vont
m'accompagner va peut-être michael le
voir en fonction de mon agenda en tout
cas merci beaucoup pour cette idée
sortie pour les juniors